Jeff Deverett, Film Producer, Entrepreneur,
Writer, Director:The deal's not a deal until
the money is the check has been
cashed and cleared in the bank.
Film Courage: Have you ever pitched
a completed film to Netflix?
Jeff: Oh yeah, yeah definitely. Well the
first one was completed mean pitched it
before but then had to pitch it after to get
it sold the second one was a completed film
Kiss and Cry that that was pitched after
the fact pitched do you want me them
mean you've already asked it so yeah pitched
another one that they said no to which think
is my best film ever but they didn't think so
and they said no and they didn't tell you why
didn't no wasn't a fit for the audience even if
they did honestly honestly don't even hear why
like because feel like it's just being polite
whatever it is like if you say it's not a fit
for your audience then their audience is so big
everything's a fit for their audience they own
the entire world audience so mean if they say it's
not an entertaining movie then truthfully guess my
ego is too big to believe that because I've done
so many screenings with it know it's entertaining
to audiences mean I've been in so many festivals
with the movie and I've watched real audiences not
friendly audiences people who know me like you
know complete strangers watch and critique the
movie so know it's an entertaining movie so when
somebody says it's not an entertaining movie then
say respectfully disagree but you get to say it
because because you own the audience and don't
but that's okay that's their
prerogative it's their business
when we played that one little game
before which really liked where you said
what's your movie and now need you to fill a
hundred seats from people that are not friends
and families co-workers whatever do you ever
run out by your students and do it and do they
well no it's because it really gets you
to think critically and and it makes the
stakes a little higher to really really dig
in and say okay who would put into those seats
and what do they say like what are some of the
ideas that these students have well it depends
on the movie you know like you know don't want
to get into too many details because you know
don't want wanna it's not fair to my students
whatever like like one of the groups did Pulp
Fiction okay you know so they went into a lot of
detail of who that movie goal would be now there's
probably tons of research on the internet that
they probably could have borrowed from don't know
but they thought about you know what age
group what demographic you know where
what that type of movie would attract that
type of thing so you know and they gave me
reasons of why they thought that was the
people and it doesn't matter again whether
it's right or wrong because there aren't no
writer there aren't right and wrong answers
it's about the reasons why you do the critical
thinking you do so they say you know they could
say that's for 12 year old girls and as long as
they tell me why they think that and it's rational
then they'll get a good mark now totally disagree
that movie is obviously not for 12 year old girls
because there's so much violence and swearing and
all that kind of stuff but they wouldn't say that
obviously but they might say you know males 50
to 70 and might say well you know it's probably
males you know 30 to 50. but you know tell me
why you think 50 to 70 and they might say because
we think that those males are more mature and have
more time and would like the violence better or
something like that as long as the reasoning is
good it's about the critical thinking because
it's constantly changing as said right so want to
create critical thinkers who who can be creative
and just be rational now they'll work in teams
ultimately when they're in the working world and
and it's good to have different input and and
different ideas you know and as long as you're
not crazy and delusional you know and coming
as long as you it's about thinking about it
that's what that's what learning is about is
about thinking critically about something and
and trying to understand it best you can it's not
about right and wrong necessarily in this this
isn't math there's not a right answer and a wrong
answer this is about how you come to it was there
a waiting period after you pitched Netflix the
first time yeah you mean until until got an answer
had the six weeks or so something like that they
had to circulate the movie internally a bit and
think about it a bit that can't remember exactly
but it wasn't it wasn't a long like it wasn't more
than that maybe maybe four weeks something like
that it was relatively soon god you know you're
sitting on pins and needles the whole time you're
so anxious but you know they do fears for you know
they have a million things to look at and they
you know they have to get opinions of few people
when Netflix said yes to you what did that yes
mean it meant that just became a real filmmaker
now it meant like it's surreal
at first to be honest with you
it's like holy smokes but first of all you gotta
understand am so skeptical about everything
because I've been in business by myself for so
long that I've seen so many deals fall apart
so the truth is and hate to say it the truth
is and do this with everything so people
if anybody who's ever worked for
me knows what I'm about to say
it's like the deal's not a deal until the money is
the check has been cashed and cleared in the bank
so even though you have a deal in writing even
though it's all signed sealed delivered you've
delivered the movie when the money comes and it
clears then it's a deal and everybody says like
why can't you just celebrate they said yes you
have a contract here it is they're taking delivery
said yeah but I've seen lots of deals there
where they falls apart at the end the very end
even though it's what are you gonna do
you're gonna assume Netflix you're a little
like lowly filmmaker and you're gonna take them
you know and you'll probably settle or something
like that if the deal were to fall through but
kind of wait until the very end so as much as
was thrilled and happy it wasn't done until it was
paid for do you think that's a good matter to go
by do you think too many people are trusting
and get their hopes up and so that's when you
said you'd been through so much and so much
rejection yeah it seasoned you in a way that
you're you're more up to close any gaps that
yeah it's not a good way to be mean it's good
to be able to really celebrate and everything
like that but but the word you use is right
it's seasoned that comes with experience mean
generally when you've done being in it enough time
that's any business not just the film business
but you know when you've done enough times and
you've seen sort of what the scenarios are and how
it plays out just don't want to set myself up for
disappointment and underst you know especially
when it's new territory like it wouldn't happen
now with Netflix now I've got enough experience
and know who they are and they're big enough
company everything like that but back then it was
the first deal didn't know what to expect and i'd
seen a deal go sour a really good deal that had
done before a few years earlier went sour at the
11th hour like it was a done deal and it went
sour and was in a position to you know sue but
pursuing is not a good route to take because it's
costly and you don't want to ruin a relationship
you know so so guess I'm a little jaded no
I'm a lot jaded but for good reason I'm am
have a lot of experience I'm super seasoned and
you get jaded when you're seasoned but do still
allow myself to celebrate when the time comes
but choose when the time is how many guaranteed
ways are there for a filmmaker to get their film
to Netflix guaranteed ways that's a kind of a
loaded question almost like it's it's like it's
like leading a witness there's no guarantees
you're talking Netflix mean the only guarantee
is mean there's two guarantees one is
you're making the movie for Netflix because
they hired you it's a Netflix original and they
hired you to make the movie that's guaranteed
because they own the movie and they hired you
or two is they pre-buy the movie from you based
on an idea or a license which highly highly
highly is unlikely those are the two guarantees
otherwise you know you do it you hope for the best
mean but both of those first scenarios are
generally Netflix original movies where it's
not really your movie you're just making it for
them what are some of the non-guaranteed ways
to get on Netflix that just shot in the dark
well the first non-guaranteed way is make a
movie make it really really good create a lot of
awareness for it you know not necessarily give
it away on youtube for free but do something
that gets a lot of maybe social media activity
something that you do special or maybe release
or something like that that's probably the best
non-guaranteed way because it will put you
in a league where you'll be able to get their
attention because now two things have happened
one is you've made a good movie it's finished
so they don't you're not pitching them on an
idea you're pitching them on a finished film
and two is you've also gotten an audience which
they want audience their business is not about
content their business is audience they're in
the business of signing subscribers remember that
the way they subsidize sign subscribers is
to create good content now they're also in
the content business now so someday they're the
value of their content library is going to be
worth a ton of money it probably already is right
now but the major asset is subscribers and they
create good content to get subscribers so if you
can show to them that you already have like a ton
of interest and maybe some of those people will
become subscribers if they put their movie your
movie on their service that's a gigantic plus for
them you know like if you're dealing with say a
niche audience right and they don't maybe have
that niche audience or think that they could sign
another you know 20 30 40 50 000 subscribers based
on that movie they're going to be all over that
so that's the best non-guaranteed way to do it
but it's you know you're making a movie it's super
risky and they also might say no and they may
never see the movie like how do you get it to them
right you gotta have an agent or a manager or
somebody or the best way as said last time is to
go through an existing distributor who already has
a relationship with them but the best way to get
that distributor is to have that audience to have
that awareness to have that notoriety already it's
not just it's not this is where the narrative is
different it's not good enough anymore to say hey
have a great movie it's not good enough even to
have laurels from you know low end film festivals
mean if you have the audience choice award from
toronto or can yeah you're good but who gets
that one movie you know a year and probably you
know so chances are you're not going to have that
what's good enough is you've done some
marketing and created a lot of awareness
and all of a sudden the distributor slash who's
going to talk to Netflix can say look how much
interest we already have we're not only bringing
a movie we're bringing an audience with it
seems like a lot of authors are doing that
as well so it's very similar they don't get
signed sometimes by these big publishing
houses until they've proven that they have
a big social media following right could be wrong
about that but but the good news is for here's the
good news for indie filmmakers if we're going to
take one piece of good news is the because of the
digital world you can actually do that now you can
actually reach out to the audience yourself now
it's a super crowded marketplace because they're
inundated with all kinds of stuff but you know 10
20 years ago you could not connect with the world
with individuals around the world now you can
like say it's just hard to get through all the
clutter but at least the it exists the technology
exists to do it so if you got a message and you
know how to work it and manage it and you know
maybe create this niche area where you can get
it out there at least it's available to do it
whereas before you had to do generic television
advertising or or print advertising whatever and
spend a ton of money and not even know
if you're connecting with your audience
is that something that your students are concerned
with how do they kind of rise above the noise
because there's so much we're inundated
with every day yeah don't think young
people are as concerned about that because
they're part of the noise they are the noise
right see it as noise because I'm used to other
stuff but but they're they are the noise right
so they're well way more connected than am
way more up to speed on all the platforms
you know it's constantly changing obviously
I'm not hip you know tell you the funniest
thing the the the one compliment my oldest son
paid to me so the back-ended compliment was
dad the only thing cool about you is that
you actually know that you're not cool
took it as a compliment okay no that was a total
compliment you know it took so much pressure off
me like didn't want to have to chase around
and try to you know pretend that knew all
these platforms and that was on instagram and
doing this and all that kind of stuff i don't
want to do tick tock videos just don't want to do
that stuff i recognize that it is super important
and that there's a gigantic world out there and
it's very big for marketing recognize it totally
but at my age and who am I'm not I'm not going
to do that I'm going to hire people or can you
know I'm going to circle myself with people who
who are good at it who want to do it who enjoy it
more than do so I'm not saying it's not important
because it totally is I'm just saying know who
am and don't want to try to be some cool instagram
you know person or don't want to be a youtube
influencer guess maybe through these videos I'm a
little bit but yeah think you all no no but what
I'm saying is like don't have to do these silly
weekly videos that you know are going to do crazy
stuff to make me don't even want to do weekly
webcasts or podcasts it's just I'm not interested
so that's what he meant at least you know who you
are and you're not interested in that now having
said that the young people are super interested
in all that kind of stuff and it's great because
the tools and listen there's a lot of people who
might be in my class or you know who are in that
generation who are going to change the world right
they're going to come up with new technologies or
they're going to work in companies that apply
these technologies and and do special things
that that are going to you know change the
way people think and and new habits and new
ways mean look what's gone on in the last
year with the whole black lives matter and
the whole mean these are social movements
that change the way people think and the
whole world and so that's great you know that
these are that's the generation that's gonna
embrace that and take and take charge and
hopefully we'll do you know do good with it
that's great that you have so many sort of ears
and eyes that are able to tell you different
things whether it's students or your sons and and
you can kind of see them in action with whatever
on whatever platform yeah you
know because some people don't and
you know there's so many things that are changing
and evolving oh this platform's not not no one's
using this now so you know it's funny for my
students so when we were doing the marketing
part and was talking about social media literally
said to them at the beginning of that lecture said
what I'm about to tell you is what know but I'm
pretty darn certain hopefully that I'm right that
you know way more than do so I'm just going to go
through the motions and in your papers I'm going
to learn more from you from in this section then
you're going to learn from me because know that
you are active on these platforms and I'm not now
we talked about buying facebook ads and stuff like
that which is you know don't do it hire people to
do that so understand how it all works and how to
target and do that kind of thing and they don't
didn't know about some of that stuff but they're
going to be way better at it than am and it's way
more savvy because that's who they are each deal
that you've received on Netflix has it improved
each time it's three films yes it has yeah
that might be a combination of a couple things one
is got lucky it could be that just got lucky that
they were paying more each time two is maybe
the films are better but don't think they're
necessarily better in terms of the production
quality but think maybe it's because they see that
my films are getting an audience and that may
be worth a bit more so they being fair really
fair because they control that side you know you
can have a little bit of a discussion but for the
most part they say here's where you're going to
fit in and if you say no they got 50 other films
waiting in line to fit in so there's a little
bit of room wiggle room but not a heck of a lot
but at least if they say you're this is what
the film is worth and and they recognize that
the value is there because they have an audience
and they know it because they had an audience for
the previous one so so it's similar audiences
so that's maybe why they've been fair like that
have you made any pitches to Netflix during
the pandemic yeah yeah of course have mean you
know the pandemic does mean can't shoot anything
but i did pitch them on the movie want to shoot
and you know they're interested but but i told
them I'm not shooting during the pandemic so
maybe that's my bad but think everybody
understands that right but it was another
scenario where it looks good sounds good we like
division we like the style of movies you make
and everything like that but you're going to
need to make it and make sure you make it well
it's still good do have a tracker with them
yeah do have relationships yeah it's still
a new adventure every time though you
know because they're I'm a little tiny
speck of dust in in their universe and know it you
know maybe shouldn't belittle myself that much but
so don't take for granted you know you got to
deliver and it's got to be good and it's got to
resonate and by the way still plan on doing all
that audience awareness stuff that talked about
even more so now now that I'm really aware of
it and real niche and lots and lots of marketing
before it goes to them if they're going to
take it so that can bring audience to them
want to be able to say the major pitches to
them is like yeah here's the story and it's
a good movie and it's going to resonate but the
major pitches look at the audience that think I'm
going to be able to bring to you because of all
the marketing I've done what constitutes niche
in the eyes of a of a platform like Netflix or
hulu or disney it's it's specific like you know
tend to make family movies and primarily sports
dramas so this one's also a sports drama based on
a true person you know true like a true true life
story so niche would be sort of what the sport is
who this the person is that we're talking about
if there's some sort of like community around
that person that would be interesting you know
to use a very very big example mean obviously
this is way bigger than what I'm talking about
but so Netflix recently released the tiger woods
you know two-part series and it wasn't it was
some filmmaker made it about tiger woods and it
was really really well done as a matter of can't
believe how well done it was based on the fact
that he didn't he wasn't part of it they like it
wasn't you know an authorized biopic they did it
based on footage they got anyways i love golf
and so so look at the niches there mean first
of all you've got the celebrity of tiger woods in
the sports world you've got the whole golf world
because pretty well anybody who's a golfer is
going to watch that so there's you know you deal
with the pga the professional golf association
and you know there's lots of associations you
know like remember the southern california golf
association everybody heard about it through that
so we all got it very niche target marketing to
the golf world obviously to the overall sports
world and then you know the general stuff is to
the celebrity world because he's a major celebrity
you know in his own right even though he's an
athlete but you know he's probably more well-known
in the world than any actor is or you know way up
there with them so but you know they say that's
an extreme example because you're talking like
probably the most well-known athlete in the world
but the niche is the golf thing right and so even
if it wasn't tiger if it was some unknown golfer
he still could have gone into the golf world
because generally like guarantee know a lot
more golfers than you know on the pga tour think
so so if they had used somebody who wasn't the
notoriety of tiger but you know somebody who was
was interested in as a golfer they could target
me and that alone would be and you know and then
it's also demographics you know generally a lot
of people who golf are more so male than female
but you know it goes both ways but you know they
there's ways to target that sure and that's a
good demographic because that's someone that's
going to have disposable income to spend
on things even if you're not putting it
on a platform where it's just whatever fifteen
dollars a month and that might be a good place
to start getting someone to yeah would imagine
mean look at Netflix has such a big audience
that always assume everybody's got Netflix but
they don't but always assume everybody does
but you know would imagine that you know there's
there were a lot of golfers who maybe don't have
a Netflix subscription that maybe did sign up for
a Netflix subscription just to watch that special
and it was well it was really well done so they
probably got their money's worth now will they
stay subscribers don't know that's up to Netflix
to start to profile them and feed them other golf
stuff or whatever stuff you know Netflix is
good at that right suggested yeah films yeah.